so Dana what do you think here is this
new Porsche going to give Elan musk a
run for his money
well let's see what happens I mean
Porsche just unveiled this concept car
but my understanding is that it won't
hit the market for about another five
years so what it really hits the market
and consumers start buying it then we'll
see how serious the competition is it's
serious the competition is is this is
Porsche just trying to one-up Tesla or
is this just something they want to do
to just keep improving their brand well
I think it's interesting that we're
finally seeing larger automakers getting
into electric drive for a long time
we've been hearing about the promise of
electric vehicles but now we're finally
actually beginning to see them at least
the concepts of them in Frankfurt five
years is a long time in the auto world
what do we expect coming out of Tesla in
2020 when this thing hits the road well
by 2020 Tesla hopes to have its model 3
out which is a less expensive fully
electric sedan due in late 2017 the
gigafactory should be up and running and
you know given the software updates the
speed of Tesla's fleet could also
improve Dana is it me but when when you
hear Porsche and then you hear electric
in the same sentence for me it seems
like there's some sort of disconnect no
pun intended well it's certainly not
something that Porsche is known for but
I think that all the OEMs are beginning
to look more seriously at electric Drive
and you know speed is something that
Porsche is is definitely working on with
this with this model how worried should
Tesla be about all the other big
automakers the luxury automakers trying
to get into the electric space you know
it's hard to say I mean Elon Musk has
always said that he welcomes the
competition if more people are looking
at electric vehicles that helps Tesla
overall for a long time Tesla has kind
of been going it alone you know Nissan
least okay sorry oh no I'm sorry
interrupt out just a green with you
Tesla has been largely going it alone
and certainly you know there's the Chevy
Volt there's the Nissan Leaf but all of
those cars are still sold in relatively
low volumes
so if more automakers come out with
electric cars and electric vehicles can
gain market share over the internal
combustion engine that ultimately helps
Tesla yeah and of course the more
electric car is the more infrastructure
there is the more power charging
stations muchel that is good news for
all the electric cars